uh yeah we are right now joined by uh
magnus carlsen the third place in the
magnus carlson invitational congrats
magnus
thank you are you um feeling very happy
about this that it ends in a good way
for you
i would say i'm very happy is a massive
exaggeration
um
uh yeah third is better than fourth
uh for sure and uh
for for the future um
obviously there will be will be a lot
more events like this
um it's good to get one over over wesley
for
for sure uh so clearly he
he was not 100 motivated and
not in his best shape but i mean
it's as i said it's it's it's a lot
better than to have to have lost
the last match and uh
i spoke about it yesterday after after i
won the first
game then i sort of um
yeah i definitely had had a clear wish
to win this match
and well david just say it said it uh
sometimes during this tournament and
definitely yesterday you've been back to
sort of your sparkling best so i'm
wondering
has it been nice to to play this uh
battle for third place
without the pressure that is usually on
you so much
yeah it's pretty clear uh during the
preliminaries and the first day of the
of the quarterfinals as well
that i actually played
played really quite well when um
when there was there was a little at
stake
and um yeah you could
you could see that uh when the pressure
was higher
in the semis then i i messed up a bit um
but i think over overall
[Music]
overall i i think i played a lot better
in this tournament
than i did in the last one so
i think it's a small step forward um
even though uh of course i would have
loved to
yeah not to to have my worst two days
um during the the semis and now of
course we are following
the final with nepo and anish do you
have sort of a favorite that you are
cheering for to win of course the
tournament with your name on it
uh no i mean i
don't spend that much time thinking
about
um
[Music]
about who wins when when i don't um
but i think yeah regardless
of who wins probably ownership's in a in
a great situation it will be
will be uh will be a wonderful full
victory for him if it's um
if you hold son how yeah how would you
evaluate
this super sharp position magnus um
obviously the computer say is 0.0 as
always but
um decent practical chances for the
pontiac to fight back and win
or will anish hold tight do you think
i guess it depends it depends a bit
on whether you can take an a6 or not
because otherwise uh
[Music]
otherwise i don't think it will be will
be easy
all right my mind is thank you for your
thoughts and congrats on that the third
place look forward to seeing the next
tournament
thanks for joining